[Music]
what brought us to this piece was the
explosive interview
that prince harry and meghan markle gave
to oprah
in march where they talked about kind of
their departure
and separation from the royal family
i think people care because it's like
the modern fairy tale
story right but what we're realizing
with this interview is that
things are a little bit more complicated
than that and they talked about
what it means to walk away what it means
to have that media attention
and what it means to be a black woman
in the royal family so i think we
through this interview saw a different
aspect of what it means to be royal
among the bombshells that they revealed
they made it really
clear that the royal family is
as much a business as they are a family
so dennis and i decided to
dig into how much money is at stake
in this business and the curious thing
about it is that
unlike other family businesses even
though they own all of these things
and they amount to a large sum of money
they account to 28 billion dollars
roughly u.s even though they can't sell
any of these items from the business
the business very much depends on
their relationship with the public and
their relationship with the press
and the public persona that they have as
a family
the royals bring in 2.7 billion dollars
in revenue to the uk economy and that
comes in different ways
the crown estate pulled in more than 700
million dollars
in revenue in the latest fiscal year
and 475 million of that was in profits
and what happens after that point is
that 25
of those profits go to the royal family
75 of that goes back to the british
treasury that 25 is what
is known as the sovereign grant and the
sovereign grant is solely used towards
public expenses
of the royal family so that could
include anything from payroll
security travel house evening
maintenance costs
the member of the royal family who has
the largest personal net worth is
naturally queen elizabeth but even then
it's relatively small compared to all of
the wealth connected to the crown
we estimate that she has a personal net
worth of about
500 million dollars u.s and
much of that is from real estate and
income that she's accumulated from the
duchy of lancaster
the crown holds a lot of things that it
cannot sell
and they add up to 28 billion dollars in
assets the biggest part of that
is the crown estate which we value at
around 19.5 billion dollars
and outside the crown estate is
buckingham palace which we estimate at
4.9 billion dollars
and the duchy of cornwall which is
estimated at 1.3 billion dollars and the
duchy of lancaster which is 748 million
dollars
by virtue of being the queen it looks
like
queen elizabeth owns it but actually she
doesn't personally own it so she can't
walk out and say i am selling billions
of dollars of real estate we have she
cannot do that
and the thing that we also report in our
piece is that
there is an independent board that
oversees the investment decisions
that this entity makes so she really
is separated from that as next in line
for the throne prince charles gets the
second largest income of any member of
the royal family
in addition to what he gets from the
sovereign grant which is about 2.5
million
u.s he also gets a much more substantial
income
from the duchy of cornwall the duchy of
cornwall is
a collection of properties across
southwest england that the crown can
rent out to
residents and farmers and businesses
and last year that brought in 50 million
dollars in revenue
from that prince charles got 30 million
dollars
he uses that income for staffing for
operations
and for his charitable activities
essentially the duchy
is his main source of income and while
he cannot sell the assets similar to the
crown estate
he is able to use that income and he
also
helps his children william and he used
to help harry as well
until harry and megan said that they're
going to step away from their duties as
royals prince william and prince harry
they got a combined 7.8 million dollars
last year
although in the interview prince harry
revealed that he is no longer getting
any of that income
the latest fiscal year through the duchy
of cornwall
prince william and his family received a
portion of eight million dollars
for their private expenses and i say
partially
because they had to share that with
prince harry
and his family so we are going to be
able to see
in a year what prince william directly
got from the duchy now that prince
harry has stepped away now that harry
and megan have stepped away from their
official duties
as part of the royal family they also no
longer get
funded security through the crown now
that they're paying for that themselves
that's something that could cost up to
four million dollars a year
although harry had received some money
from
his father's income from the duchy of
cornwall he said it wouldn't have been
possible for him and megan to step away
if he hadn't gotten an inheritance from
his late mother princess diana
now that they're free from the emotional
and financial pressures of being part of
the firm
they actually have a lot more freedom to
pursue different avenues
the couple signed a three-year
podcasting deal with spotify
that could be worth as much as 18
million dollars on top of that
prince harry also has a partnership with
oprah
for an apple tv series focusing on
mental health something that was
actually mentioned
during the interview they also signed a
100 million dollar
five-year netflix deal that entails
producing documentaries
scripted series and lots of other
content for the streamer
it's also a lot more money than what
they would have been making from the
duchy of cornwall
prince harry is sixth in line for the
throne and it's really unlikely that
he'll ever be the king of england
by stepping away from the royal family
with meghan markle
he's created an opportunity for himself
to create a billion dollar brand all his
[Music]
own
you